to community ought to support the Libyan
army and to support Libya we cannot wait
anymore there is a sense of urgency
following this rising challenges that
have been posed by Isis in Libya there
has been much focus on Iraq and Syria in
terms of Isis but we would like to see
the same attention be provided to to
Libya and the Libyan people not least
because the Libya security situation has
had some spill over into Tunisia Algeria
Michelle Chad and Egypt as this
beheading have brought to light recently
so the threats that Libya is faced with
are potentially dangerous for year of
two Libyan Shores are not far from
Italian and European shores so we have
got the international committee to be
adequately responsible in terms of
providing the Libya de Libyan army of
the weaponry and adequate military
equipment to fight terrorism what level
of support are you looking for and from
whom are we talking about ground forces
are we talking about a British American
and French joining in the aerial assault
that Egypt is mounting I mean what from
the government's perspective would you
like the threats that are currently
posed to Libya and to the international
community are limited to some thousands
of Isis fighters in Libya so we would
like to request proportionally an
adequate assistance to the Libyan army
directly we are not asking for a
military intervention from any
international or European forces there
have been some restriction that had been
fought since nineteen 2011 not least
because of the UN Security Council 1973
we would like that that the Security
Council lift those restrictions and
provide Libya with the adequate support
for the time being otherwise Libya would
slip into a chaos that we have witnesses
in Syria and Iraq for the time being the
threats are rising Isis is
expanding in Libya but for the time
being the Libyan army is saying that
it's a adequately equipped in terms of
troops in terms of air force
capabilities to fight the threats that
have been posed by Isis and other
terrorist groups such as Australia in
Libya as you know their reports today
that the insurgents the anti-government
forces have achieved some air strikes in
Libya does that mean that you would like
to see other countries joining Egypt and
carrying out aerial air cover and aerial
assaults on rebel targets the Egyptian
army has carried out with the Libyan Air
Force some strikes on Monday morning the
Libyan army has been fighting the
terrorists in Benghazi and we are about
to free Benghazi soon from the presence
of terrorists not to mention that we
have been fighting they're not too if we
were to have the adequate weaponry we we
are our army is able to fight tourism
inserts in other hotbeds of terrorism in
Libya indeed we are not yet present in
Tripoli we have positively contributed
to the Geneva process that has been
spearheaded by UN Special Representative
Bernardino Leone we would like to bring
about a political solution to the Libya
political crisis by bringing through a
government of national unity we are
committed to that but at the same time
there is a sense of urgency and we have
got to adequately and swiftly address
the rising challenges that have been
posed by terrorism in Libya finally what
would you say to people in this country
Britain but also in the United States
who say well with hindsight it was a
mistake for us to support the forces
overthrowing president Gaddafi because
for the people of Libya we've only made
the situation worse and security worse
Tunisia Libya and Egypt people have
fought some brutal and repressive
repressive regime in the past
as of 2011 and we are saying that we are
able to fight terrorism in Libya with
the need to bring about a democratic and
legitimate government and legitimate
legitimate democratic process in Libya
in Tunisia and Egypt to